des scientifiques ont mesuré la
température à la surface de la lune et
les résultats les ont surpris voici ce
qu'ils ont découvert en fait il s'agit
d'une mission du programme indien
chandraian 3 qui a fait atterrir un
engin sur la face cachée de la Lune près
du pôle Sud le 23 août d'après les
chiffres publiés par l'organisation
indienne de recherche spatiale il fait
entre 55 et 60 degrés à la surface de la
Lune mais ce n'est pas tout grâce à une
sonde capable de mesurer la température
en profondeur les chercheurs indiens ont
également analysé la température du
sous-sol du nerf et comme on le voit sur
ce graphique au fur et à mesure que la
sonde s'enfonce la température chute
rapidement à 8 cm de profondeur la
température est d'environ moins 10
degrés soit 70 degrés de différence
entre le sous-sol et la surface un écart
trois fois plus grand que ce
qu'imaginait les scientifiques avant
leur mesure puisqu'il prévoyait un écart
de 20 à 30 degrés maximum on précise que
ce n'est pas la seule mission du
programme chandry 3 pendant deux
semaines le robot indien va
cartographier prendre des images et
réaliser des analyses de la face cachée
de la Lune le surnom souvent donné au
pôle Sud
[Musique]